hello this is steve kaufman
uh i'm going to get back to this whole
subject of the korean uh golfers i mean
that's we talk about the lady
the
ladies professional golf association
which is based in the united states
that has come out recently and said that
their members
will have to be able to give interviews
in english and so forth uh it more or
less has been identified that the main
target is the korean golfers
because the koreans are so dominant now
there are mexican and taiwanese and i
don't know
what other foreign golfers um but they
either don't do very well or or in or in
the case of
those that do well they speak english
well
uh so there's been this tremendous
reaction all of the professional
anti-racist organizations are up in arms
it's an opportunity for them to stop
their stuff the
asian-american academics association and
all kinds of hand wringing is going on
and
i mean i just think it's it i'm just
amazed the um no one said that you have
to speak english in order to play golf
somewhere
this is not about discrimination the
lpga is a product
it's a it's a brand name
and the people who run that brand name
have the right to decide what
to expect of their players and if they
feel that it's important for their
players to be able to communicate
through acceptance speeches when they
win through uh interviews
uh interacting with key sponsors
i mean that's how
they can decide what the requirements of
of the job are i i just i don't
understand the issue
uh yeah there may be people who don't
like seeing so many koreans on the golf
on the ladies golf tour there may even
be people within the lpga who feel that
way
for all i know
there are maybe americans who don't like
koreans there's probably koreans who
don't like americans
that's not against the law
and the people at the lpga didn't say we
don't like koreans we don't want koreans
we don't want foreigners all they said
was we want our playboy players to be
able to communicate in english
uh they said effectively now
to me that's not difficult
uh if those foreign players are in the
united states
for months and months and months
and they have time and they're young and
they had english at school if they're
motivated they can learn enough to
conduct an interview
and they don't need a tutor
they don't need um
rosetta stone
what they need
is
an ipod either one of these
or the little truffle that i use
and it would not be difficult to create
a whole bunch of sample interviews or to
into take some interviews that other
english speakers give
provide transcript
and have these players listen to these
interviews for hours and hours
and then
if they're really smart
they would come to link
and then they would be able to use our
system to learn the language from this
material that's all they need to do in
six months they would all be able to
give interviews the worst thing would be
if the lpga hired some group of language
teachers
to come up with a test which is going to
test them for grammatical accuracy
nobody is interested in their in these
korean players grammatical accuracy
they are only the lpga wants them to be
able to communicate at some level now it
may be
that these korean players are under the
impression that they have to speak
perfect english
no
that and that would be very silly
if the lpga said they have to achieve
some level on some
test that would be very silly just to be
able to communicate so that the fans and
sponsors can actually
directly hear
what this player has to say in a
language that they can understand
i don't think that there is you know
abundant racism i don't think
tiger woods or
michelle we have heard professional golf
i know that many of these sports
organizations are interested in taking
their product
abroad into asia lots of people live in
asia japan korea china and have made
efforts in that direction i don't know
what the lpga has done
so
yeah there may be individual people who
don't like certain other people but the
issue here why not just keep it simple
what they've said is we want our players
to be able to communicate
in interviews in english
what's so difficult
uh
and i know
and i
take the opportunity to toot my own horn
but
link would work for them better than any
rosetta stone
and
there's abundant
interviews and conversations that
transcripts can be provided and all
these players have to do is listen for
six months and they would be quite
capable of providing an interview
and i mean in my own case we don't have
korean on link
uh but the principle is the same a lot
of listening reading and working on
vocabulary it's this it's what we make
more efficient at link but that's
basically how you learn languages don't
bother giving your interview for six
months don't bother even talking for six
months don't get a tutor don't waste
your time just get out your ipod and
listen a lot and get the language into
your brain
now i did that with korean about three
or four years ago i did it for about six
months
uh an hour a day here and there and uh
it's been three years so i've forgotten
a lot but i'm going to say a few words
in korean just to demonstrate that one
needing to be one needn't be afraid of
making mistakes and what i'm about to
say is going to be full of mistakes but
it doesn't matter because a korean
person will understand me
and may i mean
they don't care about me speaking korean
but if i were a pro golfer that had just
won
the
korean golf championship and i was
interviewed and was able to say
something in korean
the fans would appreciate it they would
make that would make me popular they
would want me back
so um now here goes my korean
uh
um
um
uh
anyway you get the picture i'm
struggling okay i haven't been at it for
a while
so but if i decided i mean
particularly in the case of giving
interviews i mean the fact is that those
interviews are pretty brain dead well
you know i had to keep you know
you know an even keel out there play one
hole at a time and focus on
whatever and
i don't know what all they say but
there's not many different variations in
the interview so to develop the ability
to do an interview it's not that
difficult and i think the other thing is
that they have to want to communicate i
mean it's their tournament as much as it
is or at least it's their tour as much
as it is anyone else's they're part of
that community they are all together
promoting that package so they
should want to be part of the community
talk to the other golfers
do things to make it better and i read
in an interview that
sari park and some of the other korean
golfers said yeah
they don't like the fact that there's
kind of they're going to be fined or
kicked out or something obviously but
um they agree with the principle and
apparently they haven't done enough to
get better despite pressure from the
lpga so now there's been this publicity
i think it's a good thing and i think
we're going to see them all
do a better job with their english and
that's what i have to say